let p q r and s be the points on the
plane with position vectors negative 2i
minus j
4i 3i plus 3j and negative 3i plus 2j
respectively the quadrilateral pqrs must
be uh so let's just let's just graph
each of these position vectors or graph
the points that they're specifying so
let me draw my coordinate axes right
over here
so that would be this
is my vertical let me draw i could draw
a straighter line than that and there
you go
that's about as good as i can do
we draw the horizontal
that's a better job i think
and then let me mark it off let's see we
go as high as 4
we go up to 4i so 1 2 3
4. we go as low as negative 2i so 1
2
just making sure let me make it a little
bit even because we have to figure out
the shape of whatever we draw then we're
gonna go
up three
we're gonna go up three one
two
three and i think that and we actually
go down one as well so i think that'll
give us and we could keep marking them
off if we wanted to
we don't need to based on the positions
that have been specified so let's draw
these vectors let's draw
vector p first negative 2i
minus j so negative 2i i is along the
horizontal or you can imagine it's the x
coordinate so negative 2i
minus j so it is this position vector
right over here if we put it in standard
form starting with its base
at the origin it's that position vector
but it's specifying that point over
there which is the coordinate negative
two negative one so that's we could let
me just write it down negative two
negative one
now let's do
4i so 4i is literally we just go that's
just 4 in the x direction 1 2 3 4.
there's no y component or there's no j
component no vertical component so it
specifies
it specifies that position right over
there or it specifies the point
four comma zero
then we have
three i plus three j so one two three
one two three that is that point right
there the position vector specifies that
point
or the specifies the point three comma
three
and then finally we have negative 3i let
me just another color negative 3i so 1 2
3 plus 2 j 1 2. so right
right over there so that is that last
position vector and specifying the point
negative 3 comma 2. and they want to
know what's the quadrilateral made by
these four positions so let's draw it
let's connect the dots
so this is p
go to q
it gets us that line right over there
then from q to r
we're gonna go like that
we're gonna go like that and then from r
to s we're gonna go like
we're gonna go like that and then
and then actually it's gonna go a little
bit more it's going to go like
that
and then from s
sorry that's from s to r and then r 2
and and then and that's from sorry
that's from r to s and then s to p is
going to be like that so just eyeballing
it it's clearly not a square
it's clearly not a square it's clearly
not a rectangle it's coming off at
different angles
it's clearly not it's clearly not a
rhombus a rhombus would have all of the
same side so square would be all 90
degrees
would be all the same sides and all the
angles are 90 degrees that would be a
square it's clear not a square rectangle
would be all the angles are 90 degrees
but the sides two sides are going to be
the same and the other two sides are
going to be the same this is not these
do not look like 90 degree angles now
the last one and you could you could try
if you want i mean just eyeballing it
it's pretty clear these aren't 90 degree
angles but if you wanted to you could
see find the slope of this and find the
slope of that line and if they're not
the negative inverse of each other then
they're not perpendicular and they're
not coming at 90 degree angles and so
the last one is are they a rhombus a
rhombus is a parallelogram while the
sides are the same so rhombus would look
like a rhombus would look like that
clearly not a rhombus that these sides
are clearly much longer than those sides
over there now just from deductive
reasoning it looks like the answer is a
it's a parallelogram but we can verify
it we can make sure we can make sure
that in order for this to be a
parallelogram
these two sides have to be parallel and
these two sides
and these two sides have to be parallel
or another way to think of it they would
have to have the same slope so we could
verify if we were taking this on exam
under time pressure we'd just cross
these out and it looks pretty good we
would just go with a but let's just
verify it so what's the slope what's the
slope down here
what's the slope down here so it's
change in y over change in x so 0 minus
negative 1
0 minus negative 1
over
4
minus negative 2 or this is equal to 1
over
4 minus negative 2 is positive 6. this
is 1 6. or another way to think about it
we ran 6 and we only rised 1 there's 1
6. now what happens over here well it's
the same thing we're going from negative
3 to
3 so we're running 6 so we say 3 minus
negative 3 is equal to 6 and how much
did we rise we have 3
minus 2 which is equal to 1. so this is
also a slope of 1 6. so these two lines
are clearly parallel and now let's do it
for these other two what's the slope
over here
what's the slope over here and actually
you can just do rise over run
rise
over run
so this is that's exactly what we're
doing before but just to give you the
taste for everything so we ran to go
from here to here we have to move to the
right one so we run one and how much do
we rise well we have to go down three
we have to go down three so it's
negative three so the slope here is
negative three and what about here to go
from this point to this point we went to
the right one so we ran one and we had
to go down we started at two we ended up
at negative one we had to go down three
so the slope here is also
negative three so these lines are also
parallel so we're definitely dealing
with a parallelogram which is neither a
rhombus nor a rectangle